the only
comparator we have unfortunately is
almost like the flu pandemic
1918. why i'm saying this because this
was clearly
a pandemic of a respiratory virus
where there was no human intervention
infection prevention measures were very
very very limited it was
war on top so you had crowding you had
very bad hygiene
hygiene genie conditions etc and there
was no vaccine
so there first of all what we have seen
we have seen no variance
the whole thing happened within one year
and and people have been sampling
or analyzing autopsy samples to see
whether it was any variation in the in
this range that
you know during this pandemic appeared
in several different parts of
of the world and it was very homologous
so that is one thing now so that is that
is very important because this is a high
infectious pressure
a natural pandemic no human intervention
so if you imagine now that we have
like every second or third we
we have a new uh infectious variant
appearing
and not only is this a more infectious
variant
it's very often also much more
infectious like in the brazilian
compared to the uk etc
and uh it all appears very rapidly it's
not like
during evolution of course you know
these things appear
and if they have a competitive advantage
they will replace the original
strength now all this is happening
multiple variants
within a short period of time with
dramatically increased infectivity
and this in parallel with with the mass
vaccination campaign
i mean as i was saying you have the same
pandemic
well it was flu of course nothing
happens in
terms of variance there were a few
mutations but
here the mutations are very clearly
targeted they are selected
at domains that enhance the infectivity
fires so they are not like random they
are really selected
towards parts of the of the spike
protein that are responsible for
effectivity
so i mean there is something there right
oh yes we need to to agree upon this
same same for example if you look if you
imagine now the the
the situation in chile for example okay
so you
are vaccinating you're vaccinating on a
background
of a variant that had just appeared
right i mean the brazilian
the brazilian variant so this brazilian
variant is of course pretty much
different the s protein from the s
protein of the vaccine
if you know start vaccinating people of
course
this variant that just emerged
is going to have a competitive advantage
because it's more infectious and what
you'll want to do with your antibodies
is to prevent infectivity
so now all of a sudden you see how this
variant is exploding
and you see the infectious rates that
are dramatically increasing
so all of a sudden you have a much
higher infectivity rate right
and so there is other criteria as well
that we could uh
uh the mutations are of course studied
and
we see more and more that they are also
now
converging towards domains that are
targeted by the vaccinal antibodies
so if you take all these things together
we
we should be able compared as you
pointed out correctly to a natural
pandemic
to observations that are really high
very very strange
and that according to my humble opinion
could be correlated
with at least i would say human
intervention right in this pandemic
so uh if i can make that a little bit
simpler what you're saying is a
something that surprised me the first
time i heard you say it which is that in
the
1918 pandemic there was apparently
there were no widespread variants and we
know this
from the comparison of samples taken
during
autopsy so that shocks me i think what
it suggests
is that the evolutionary experimentation
took place before the pandemic that
effectively the virus got very effective
at uh transmitting in some small
population that wasn't captured
in the autopsy samples maybe it wasn't
even recognized as a unique disease
and that by the time it circulated
around the globe
it was already highly effective and that
in this case
we have well a i would say the anomalous
fact
of this virus apparently having emerged
in the human population
already highly effective we have no
evidence for that experimental
evolutionary period at the beginning
which is one of the reasons that many of
us believe the
laboratory origins hypothesis is
probably correct
but in the context of this
vaccine campaign what you're arguing is
that we are seeing
exactly the pattern of change that you
would predict if we were creating this
inadvertent
serial passage experiment in the human
population we are putting pressure
on the spike protein in this narrow way
we are seeing change in the spike
protein and in exactly the domains that
would
cause immune escape and that you know
uh the let's put it this way i think the
um
presumption would have to be that we are
driving that change or at least
accelerating that change
by virtue of the very intense and very
narrow evolutionary pressure that we are
applying to the virus
well frankly speaking brett if you would
ask me
set up an experiment where you adapt
a variant to immune pressure
but do it in humans or do you do it in a
mammalian population
what would you do you would of course
first of all
make sure you have a high viral load
you would make sure that as many people
as possible
are in the same situation of a
suboptimal immune
in your response and
i mean if you have already if you can
already start with variance where the
match
is already suboptimal then it's even
better
right so that is exactly what you would
do that is exactly what you would do to
adapt
and what what is worrisome right
is the the kinetics of all these this is
all
going very very fast right i mean the
appearance the emergence of all these
variants and i i mean as i was saying
there is
probably a whole series of variants that
have not been
identified yet and and but it's not like
any variance
many of these variants are selected
towards for example a higher
higher infectivity and when we come now
more and more with antibodies etc we see
already that
some of these mutations are abolishing
the effect of certain antibodies within
within the polyclonal serum
of the vaccinal antibodies so it is very
well
directed it is fast it is pretty huge
because i mean
as i was saying if there is a mutation
just by
an antigenic uh drift for example
and that mutation happens to be a little
bit more
infectious than the original strain then
in the course of time it will take over
but this will be pretty slow
right evolutionary speaking here these
things are like
accelerated enhanced and it's difficult
to deny that this is not really in
parallel with
with with the mass vaccination campaigns
or with with human intervention
because as i was saying during the the
flu pandemic nothing was
seen and you could argue as well people
must have mounted uh antibody responses
right
during the flu pandemic i mean it was
not like
there there's no immune response so
um you have said if you were going to
set up an experiment
to uh induce the
effectively gain of function here it
would look more or less like
this campaign i would say evolutionarily
we can describe this very simply that
effectively we have given
the virus a gentle evolutionary
evolutionary slope
for which it can discover
high infectivity and escape from
[Music]
immune surveillance so that's all
um that's all quite
frightening that not only does the
pattern
in the wild seem to match the fears of
somebody
who is well positioned to say here's
what you would expect to see if my
hypothesis
is correct about um about immune escape
so that that raises a number of
different questions i mean it raises
the question about what
should we be doing vaccine wise well
brett i i'm a little bit hesitating
if for a second we should come back
to the innate immune response oh and
the connection to the young because
because
i mean you could say well if there is
immune escape
worst case scenario is that the vaccine
won't work anymore and that is then the
other argument we will produce new
vaccines right
but my main argument really that is my
key argument
is that even though the antibodies
may no longer neutralize the virus
they will still be able to bind to the
spy protein
and all this is science because people
have been showing that for example
antibodies
against the common cold virus right
they do not neutralize or cross
neutralize
covid19 for example or sars cov2
but they do bind they do bind to this
protein but they do not neutralize it
so if antibodies are no longer
completely functional in the sense that
they can neutralize the virus they can
still bind
bind to the s protein and there comes my
big
argument and therefore we need to come
back to these natural antibodies
by binding 2ds protein
this antigen-specific antibodies
are capable of out-competing natural
antibodies and that is that is the
disaster because as we were saying at
the beginning
the natural antibodies they are not
antigen specific
they have the capacity to broadly
neutralize
not only all kinds of covet variants but
even all types of corona
viruses and maybe you want to jump in at
this point to
to make it a little bit clearer to sure
yeah this is such a fascinating
point but uh what we have
is the possibility of antibodies that
are ineffective
at preventing the spike protein from
binding the receptor and therefore
ineffective at preventing
infection that would nonetheless attach
themselves electromagnetically they
would just simply stick
to the spike protein and they would
block the innate immunity
that we all have some degree of and that
young people appear to have a great deal
of
and therefore take the immunity that
works best and neutralize it
without creating a new immunity that
would take its place
that's um you know again that's a it's a
wild argument but i see nothing wrong
with it logically logically speaking
this makes a great deal of sense well
you know brett
i i'm going to be very open with you the
the field of natural antibodies
is not well recognized or known in the
field of vaccinology
it is well known by immunologists
frankly speaking there are there is
dozens of papers on these natural
antibodies and how fascinating they are
as i was saying they are a little bit
you know in parallel to the nk cells
they recognize
patterns they recognize patterns of
antigens
but this field is
is so neglected so underestimated
i i'm sure that many vaccinologists
don't even
really understand what natural
antibodies are about and what they can
do
because there is a lot of documentation
on this and there is even documentation
i will tell you i will tell you the
nicest documentation is
you know about the blood groups right
ado et cetera
so these blood groups these are uh
glycosylated structures
right glycans sugars for the people who
don't understand what glycogens are
and so for example if you have uh if
your blood group
group is o for example you will have
antibodies natural antibodies all
documented all in papers in publications
you will have natural antibodies
against for example the blood group
a blood group a is
a sugar and acid acetyl
galactosamine right and
so now interestingly enough if
the virus is now grown in a cell
in a mammalian cell in a target cell
that belongs to somebody who has
blood group a right then
as the virus is burning if when the
virus is
leaving it's released from the cell
membrane
it has an envelope of course that
envelope because
it's partly you know part of the
membrane of the target cell it will
also have this blood group a antigen
and when such a virus is encountered
by somebody who has blood group o and
who has
natural antibodies against blood group a
this will the virus will be destroyed
and this has been proven
not for sarsko v2 but for sarsko with
one
that these natural antibodies will
prevent
the virus and the s antigen from
interacting with the ac2 receptor
right i mean it's not like there is no
evidence there is no points also the
binding forces between the
multimeric natural antibodies and the
specific
specific antibodies are completely
different
you know the the type of chemical bonds
the one is the multivalent interaction
which is
much weaker than the s-specific binding
for example
i mean there is many many things
documented there is
also very well documented that natural
antibodies
can prevent influenza infection against
a whole range of variants
all this is in the literature so it's
not like
i'm the crazy guy just inventing some
stuff and
making putting pieces of a puzzle that
doesn't exist in reality together
to make a fancy story right it is it is
really
it is really highly likely that if you
have a specific antibodies
binding but not neutralizing your virus
that they can prevent the natural
antibodies from
from acting on that virus and that is as
you pointed out
your specific antibodies are no longer
functional
and you have no substitute for it
because
you put your natural antibodies out of
business
[Music]